[Music]
you
hello friends welcome back to this
lecture on problem solving
now this lecture is a continuation from
the previous lecture which we in which
we saw what is problem solving what is
the nature of problem solving and what
is the problem
comprise off and after that looking at
what the problem comprises off we also
looked at whether different kinds of
problem to exist and we looked at
Mayer's definition of number of type of
problems which could actually exist so
we looked at five different kind of
problem and we saw how these problems
differ from each other
what is the nature of these problems and
how do they differ from each other in
what respects then we looked at
something about how to solve a problem
so we looked at two basic approaches to
the solution of problems the first
approach that we looked at was the
approach that behaviorist took in terms
of Skinner's idea of context idea of law
of redness and how does a problem solve
in terms of associations which are made
between correct responses and the
consequences of it so that was one
approach to solving problem in terms of
the behaviorist in terms of the
behavioral psychology and the next
approach that we saw in last class which
helped us understand how to solve
problem was in terms of the gestalt
approach which talked about problem
solution as reorganization of the items
or materials available in a problem or
so what this approach said is that
problem solution is about reorganizing
the problem elements in such a way that
a novel solution comes up and so if they
talk about something called the eye
experience or the insight and so this is
what in brief we saw in the last class
and in addition to this we also saw the
cognitive approach to solution
a problem and there we discuss the idea
of renewal and saya
Simon's based on novels in Simon's idea
of what information processing theory is
the idea of a GPS the general problem
solver and so this GPS basically then
talks about how to break the problem
into its subproblems and then arriving
at the largest solution of the problem
in terms of integrating smaller problems
or inter finding solutions to smaller
problems of the larger problem now what
do I mean by this
take a large problem break up into
smaller problems then arrive at
solutions for smaller problems integrate
them together and then arrive at a final
solution of the larger problem and that
is what the idea of the general problem
solver was and the concept of a general
problem solver now what are we going to
do in today's class now in today's
lecture we will see what is a solution
to a problem how does solution to a
problem arises and not only that we'll
also see what are the problems in
solving a problem what are the
hindrances which are out there in
solving a problem so when problems or a
solution occurs or when we try to solve
a problem what are the kind of obstacles
that we face and how to go about these
obstacles how to take care of these
obstacles in addition we'll also see the
several factors which go ahead and help
us are basically better or increase or
decrease problem
solution so let's starts to raise
lecture by something called
representation of a problem so solving a
problem by using any of the ways either
it is a guest artists approach or using
a behavioral way requires the first step
of it requires to encode a problem now
as I said problem formulation itself or
the idea of a problem itself is to
understand some kind of hindrance some
kind of a uneasy State and representing
this uneasy state as a mental
presentation is what problem is all
about so basically the first step in
problem solver solution is encoding the
problem or basically making a mental
representation of the problem that one
is facing and so several problems or
several hindrances or obstacles can
arise at this very first phase where
somebody might not be able to represent
a problem or form a good representation
a mental representation of a problem now
remember in long-term memory one of the
problems that we faced or one of the
things that we looked into is something
called forget and one of the rules of
forgetting or one of the theories of
forgetting was in terms of the fact that
the problem or the information which was
thought to be encoded in the long-term
memory well they were encoded and that
was basically due to poor encoding or
due to non encoding of the problem
forgetting happens
a similar situation arises here one of
the problems or one of the obstacles in
problem solving could be at the very
first stage of problem solution which is
encoding or forming of mental
representation and that is called
problem representation so let's go ahead
and look at what is problem
representation now problem solving it
involves the process of converting a
presented information into some type of
internal mental representation so as I
said the first step in the problem
solution is to take up a problem or to
take up the elements of a problem and
then to do an actual encoding of it in
terms of mental representation that is
the first step so no matter what problem
you face whether it is writing a paper
or going somewhere or eating something
no matter what the problem is first you
need to understand this problem first
you need to understand the related items
in this problem or what is the problem
the question that the problem is posing
to you and then to go ahead and do
exactly presentation or do some kind of
mental representation of this into the
mind now within the framework of the GPS
problem solver a problem representation
involves correctly specifying the
problem space that we correctly
identifying the initial state as well as
the goal state and the operators which
must be applied and within the
constraints of the problem so basically
then problem representation in terms of
the GPS solver in terms of the GPS
sequencing is about finding out the
problem space defining the problem space
or laying out the boundary conditions of
the problem space so what we get to do
here is that if this is the idea of my
problem space problem representation
basically involves defining the
boundaries of this problem so this is my
GPS solver this space and not only
defining the boundaries of this space
but it also leads us to understanding or
identifying what is the initial state
where is the problem starting and where
is my sub goal so these are the several
sub goals which are there this is my
initial State or I guess I would write
and this is my goal state GSI right so
basically identifying this is what are
the parameters of these is and what are
the parameters or attributes of this
goal state so what will the problem look
like an initial state is what will the
problem look like at the goal state also
in addition to it
a problem representation also involves
finding out the constraints what are the
constraints so given the fact that this
is the boundary condition and these are
the attributes of the initial and the
final state the said there will be
several constraints in solving this
problem so what are the several
constraints now one constraint could be
how we can divide the problem into
smaller parts so what are the
constraints or sort of the rules into it
and further to that it may also define
about the different operators through a
different solution for example this goal
state or this sub goal may be solved by
using behavioral approaches but this
goal state may
be solved by using the gestalt approach
right or this cold state could be solved
by using another kind of approach which
is that and so each state or each sub
goal here may be solved by using
different approaches but then what I'm
getting at final is this is the initial
state of the sub goal and this is the
final state of the sub goal so here I
get the solution and then I take from
this solution and this solution now
becomes my secondary initial state and
then I move on so this is what it
basically involved so in in general what
the problem representation really means
is to find out the initial state of the
problem face find out the goal state of
what the problem will look like
identifying the constraints the
hindrances which is out there which are
they're ready to block you for solving
the problem and also in addition to that
the type of operators driver solution
mechanisms type of solution on analysis
that you will use to solve the problem
so basically this is what is problem
representation for example look at this
problem now I will give you one minute
to look at this problem and come up with
a solution let me see if you can come up
with a solution to this so starting now
I'll wait for one minute
so coming back to the problem I hope
that you are able to solve this problem
most of you would have been able to
solve this problem so basically it's
it's the problem talks about two moms
going up and down or one mob monk going
up a particular Hill starting at sunrise
and reaching there at sunset and then
starting at sunset and reaching towards
the downhill position from where he
starts at the sunset so basically what
the problem ask is to find out to verify
whether there is a point which the monk
is going to cross both while ascending
the mountain and descending them now you
realize that what is the solution to
this do you understand what is the
solution to this and so most for most
people who start writing mathematical
equations to solve this problem you will
not be able to solve this problem by
this and this is what I mean by problem
representation which is basically
understanding what a problem is and I am
presenting you the solution the easiest
possible way to solve this problem is
using a visualization and so what I'm
going to do is show you a visualization
of the menthe problem and so if you do
the visualization like this again coming
back to the solution so if this is the
problem the solution is doing a
visualization and as you see if I do a
visualization these two people go up and
down the mountain and so there is a spot
where they are going to meet and so the
easiest way to look at this problem is
doing the visual visualization or visual
interpretations of it and so if you use
any other interpretation or nyrians or
operator to solve this problem you may
not arrive very easily at the solution
of this problem right so this is
basically what is problem representation
to identify what the problem is and to
understand the sequence to understand
how it should be solved now I give you
another problem try to solve this
problem now give you 30 seconds it is a
very easy problem I will give you 30
seconds to solve the problem and let's
see if you can solve this problem
right so here goes the time and so on
more than 30 second over so basically
then did you solve the problem and most
of you would have been able to now what
we realize here is that in this
particular problem what we need is we
need a mathematical representation so in
comparison to the visual representation
that we used in the last problem the
kind of representation the kind of
solution the kind of operator that we
are going to use in this particular
solution or this particular problem is
the mathematical operator and so in this
way the problem gets solved easily so if
you do a visual representation of this
you are not able to solve a problem and
so this is what problem representation
talks about it talks about that at the
very initial phase we have to understand
how to solve the problem or represent
the problem in the correct format
now rigidity in representation now
problem solutions to problem what
hindrances the problems or a solution
may arise because people get rigid about
solving a representation or people
become rigid in representing a problem
so the initial representation of problem
is basically it's critical and failure
to represent these kind of
representations will lead to number of
factors now one of the first factor is
that sufficient attention has not been
given to the problem so when a problem
is presented to you and if you do not
pay sufficient attention to parts of the
problem or to the problem as a whole
what would happen is that you will not
be able to identify the key elements of
the problem and this will lead to you
identifying the problem itself and
representing it in the correct form and
once a problem is represented in the
incorrect form a solution will not be
most probably the solution will not be
arrived at now the second problem or the
second hindrance is that problem
elements have not been understood what
would have happened in this case is that
even if you put some attention to it or
more attention to a problem you did not
understand the various elements of the
problem or what is it asking you so
basically it is like looking at a
question and not understanding what the
question is asked
you and so some people make questions
like that which which has a lot of so
basically in most open-ended questions
or open textbook questions you get the
question in such a way that the question
revolves around certain things but there
are certain key elements that you need
to realize and once you realize these
key elements you'll be able to solve a
problem and so another problem element
or another factor which helps in problem
solving or which hinders problem solving
is not understanding or not realizing
the various elements of the problem and
what relation they have to each other
the third problem that could arise or
third obstacle that could arise is
previous experiences similar problem may
not have led to encoding the problem
elements in a rigid manner so what would
have happened in since some examples of
the present problem and this is
basically called analogous problem
solving so when solving a problem due to
past experiences what we tend to do is
not look at a problem in a particular
way but think of the problem in some
fixed manner and that is basically a
reason for fingers in problem solving so
instead of thinking independently
thinking about a problem independently
realizing a problem or independent
focusing your attention on to certain
elements of the problem we tend to use a
heuristic approach to it matches the
problem to some already stored format of
how it was all previously and that could
lead to problem not being solved or it
into incorrect representation of the
problem now some of the major entrances
to problem solving arises from something
called mental said so what is it it is a
tendency to rely on habits and
procedures use in the past and this is
what is mental said so basically if I
know or basically if I think of solving
a problem in a particular way I tend to
basically use that format and take a new
problem and fit it into that format and
if I do that what happens is the
solution becomes difficult so this this
basically idea this basic idea of using
a mental set or using a previous habit
of solving a problem in particular may
leads you to leads you to incorrect
representation of the problem and
thereby leads to solution other
incorrect solutions of the problem
now look at a question here and so this
is the problem which I asked so there
are six eggs in a basket six people take
one of these ejects now how is it that
one egg is still left in the basket now
most of you would worry about the fact
that how does this happen
but then hidden within this is the
representation problem and mental said
says that six people took six different
takes so how is it that one the one egg
is still in the basket the solution to
this region you have to realize that was
the last person who took the egg also
took the basket with him and then it is
possible that the last egg is still in
the basket and what when when you to
think of this in terms of six different
people
the mathematical variable then you think
six people going away taking six
different eggs and don't realize that
the sixth person can also take a basket
with it
and so there is whether mental set is
all about so the mental said they tends
to affect the representation phase of a
problem solving as past experiences
leads to inappropriate representation of
a problem so what mental sets intends to
do is that as I said there are certain
past mental representations and these
mental representations are these
inappropriate ways of representing a
problem actually makes you think of a
problem a solution in a particular fixed
way and that leads to incorrect
representation of the problem and
incorrect solution to that particular
problem another factor which is of
importance or which is of any importance
to solutions of problems or in terms of
representation a solution to the problem
is something called functional fixedness
what is it please what does it mean it
refers to people's tendency to view
objects in a narrow fixed sense right in
terms of the typical functions of an
object so in functional fixedness what
we tend to do is that we just look at
something in a particular way in a
particular manner so a spoon for example
should be looked at or is looked at only
as a spoon something which is for eating
we do not think of a spoon as a lever
and so what we can do is you can use you
can think of a spoon as a lever and then
use it to raise the the upper part of a
team or if you
Tim can and there is a lid to the tin
can we can wedge the spoon between the
tin can and the lid and apply pressure
to it basic physics basic simple physics
and that can help us in opening the lead
of a tip but then we don't realize it
and functional fixedness says that a
spool is thought of as a spool and so it
should not be doing anything else or
using the down part of a toothpaste the
bottom of a toothpaste as a tongue
cleaner nor do - I'm sorry tooth brush
and so the tooth brush is thought of as
the tooth brush and so we do not think
of it as a tongue cleaner and so but
there are certain toothbrushes are
available and so functional fixedness
what it says is that certain objects are
seen as that object are having a fixed
function and it cannot be seen as having
another function or more functions out
of it so one development perspective
says that functional for a fixed Ness
they pick up or they start or they hold
on to people as they grow older in age
so younger children are more flexible in
terms of functional fixedness they can
they are not harmed by or they are not
troubled by functional fixedness but
people as they grow in age they become
this narrow sense they approach at this
narrow sense of how a functional or
water functional fitness fixed nurses
now look at this particular problem this
is called the two string problem now I
will give you 30 seconds to look at this
problem and tell me how to solve this
and I can bet you that due to functional
fixedness you will not be able to answer
this question
and though once you are able to see this
problem pretty sure that you are not
able to solve this problem
the reason here is that functional
fixedness the certain items which have
been mentioned the chair the plier and
all those have been represented as
represented in your memory in a fixed
way and so you are not able to solve
this problem but a solution is there of
this problem and this is the simple
solution what cart has to do is to climb
up into the chair hold one end of the
string onto the other end of string he
has to tie the pillar make a swing out
of it go and stand on this chair and
then basically hold on to this string
now if if you put a pillar here it will
come back to you and then you are
holding on to this and so you can go
ahead and then tie it together that is
what is so he has to recognize that he
can use the pillar as a novel function
as a weight for the pendulum as I said
this is the swing that it will do so try
the pillar here it will work function as
a pendulum and you can always go ahead
and solve the problems and so what what
people don't understand is the pillar is
used the plier here is used for
mechanical things for basically use or
tightening of screws and all and so you
don't realize that the player can also
be used as an object for swinging or for
making a pendulum and that way you can
tie up that and so this solution problem
to solution arises from the fact that
you are not able you are functionally
fixated by certain functions of these
objects now another interesting thing
the basic problem which can arise with
solutions of problem is something called
stereotyping so Serio typing threat
occurs when a member of a negatively
stereotyped group fuse that the
stereotype might be used as to judge
their behavior thus resulting in a
negative judgment so here in this kind
of a problem solution or present problem
representation what would happen is that
since a certain groups have been
stereotyped in certain way they are not
able to register the problem or
represent the problem in a correct way
and so problem the problem if not
represented in the correct way
could not be generated and so Queenan
Spencer 2001 they use men and women to
solve math problem by using either word
word representation of it or a numerical
representation of it and this is what
they form so this is the kind of problem
that is out there and so this problem
represents a statement or basically it's
a word problem and so this kind of
problem was given to people know so this
is a word problem it can this problem
can also be represented in this
particular format so either you
represent the form of the problem in
this format which is now a word problem
or I could use as oblique problem or an
equation problem or equation format of
it so two representations are that and
so it was believed that or there was a
need or this study basically proposed
that women would solve more of numerical
problem then in in word so what are the
same problem in terms of what when it is
related in terms of word for then when
it is related in terms of an equation
and this is the results from Queen and
Spenser study it was found that the
males and females so word problem more
males there and less males were able to
solve the word problem and more measures
were able to solve the numeric format so
this is the numeric format of the
problem and this is the word format and
in terms of the fact that now it was
proposed that more women would be
solving the word problem more women
would be about ending the word problem
and solving it much easily but the
solution represents that only eight
women out of the total number of people
which has been given this solution only
eight preferred the word format for it
most women for men or they use the
numerical format or they applied the
numerical format and through the
numerical format they were much easier
for them to arrive at a solution and so
this is basically Jindal industry
typing are basically stereotyping so
basically due to CBO typing initially it
was believed that women would be more
comfortable in solving the words
representation of the same problem but
then this is not what the solution is
and so this is another reason for
representation problem representations
or obstacles in problem representation
not solutions to problems
now once the problems has been
successfully transformed from an
externally presented information into an
internally presented information the
next phase of problem solving involves
searching for and testing evaluating of
solutions so once a problem has been
encoded in the right format a right
representation of it has to be done now
a problem solving process has to be
evaluated or it has to be searched off
how to solve this problem now within the
context of Numan enzyme is 1972 IP
approach information processing approach
from the solution amounts to traveling
through the problem space so basically
in terms of problem representation it is
identifying the initial state what is
the initial state of a problem so in a
GPS solver in a GPS prob problem solving
space the problem representation is
basically at this point where we need to
identify what is the initial state of
the problem or how it the problem should
be represent in the initial State
whereas the solution to a problem
requires us to move to this state from
the initial to the goal state and
realizing how to move from the initial
state to the goal State
now there are several ways of how to
solve a problem and the first
interesting way our first important way
of how problems can be solved is using
the algorithmic approach or using
algorithms so what our algorithms then
algorithms are a set of rules that can
be applied systematically to solve
certain type of problems so these are a
set of rules these are a certain list of
rules which when applied in the correct
format which when are applied in the
correct sequence or which applied which
one applied sequentially will finally
always give you the solutions so that is
the best part of an algorithm an
algorithm is a set of steps set of steps
bounded by rules now once you use these
set of steps
once you pass through all the set of
these steps which have been there then
you really finally arrive at a solution
and that is guaranteed so almost all
gorillas guarantee a solution to it
right now mathematical formula is a good
example of an algorithm so you have to
go through the number of steps which is
there a formal solution you cannot jump
and if you go through a number of steps
you are always going to solve the
problem and remember from a real classes
of how an algorithm is written I'm
terribly sure that most of you had
mathematics till plus 12 and so if if
that is what it is then you do know what
in algorithm is so basically then how to
define an algorithm for making T the
idea is that you have to describe a step
two step process from right from taking
water into a pan going deleted or adding
something into it and in the
step-by-step manner you will always end
up by making that T so algorithm is a
set of sequences or a sequence of steps
which when followed in the correct order
it always guaranteed a solution and so
one way of finding solution to problem
is using the algorithm and so the tool
for example look at this problem two
short sides of a triangle at three
centimeter and four centimeter so what
is the hypotenuse it has to be 5 so a
square plus B square is C square that is
how we look into it and so then this way
it has to be 5 centimeter and so this is
an algorithm that is a correct way of
doing it and so we know that this is how
it has to be solved so algorithms are
very powerful problem-solving techniques
applied correctly an algorithm is always
giving you the correct solution if there
is an existing look at this initial
problem that we encounter now if we need
an algorithm to solve this problem there
will be several obstacles or there will
be several states or there will be
several steps into it for example what
would happen is it will lead to since it
is 2 3 4 5 6 it is 6 so to lead to
basically 6 factorial number of
representations which is there now what
do I mean by this what will happen is
that initially I will just change the
last two letters so this the next letter
is n I then I will change the third
letter and so one letter at a time I can
upon changing and then arrive at a
problem this is basically using the
algorithm approach so in algorithm
approach all the representations are all
changes within this letter all
arraignments different arrangements will
will be there and from that final
solution will be outputted now if you do
that you would have to do these many
number of representations of these many
number of variations into it to finally
arrive arrive at the answer that this
will lead to whitening as the answer now
there are several shortcomings to using
the algorithm as I said now if we
requires these many steps if it requires
these many variations which are out
there if it requires us to do these many
variations for arriving at a solution
then it is a it's a huge task now when
it is a huge task so basically then
there are some shortcomings to it and so
what are the shortcomings first the
exhaustive nature make them overly
Tydeus in quite impractical what would
happen is since 6 sec toriel times doing
it these many times doing all
representations all for all number of
variations on this so each letter being
varied in not only in relation to itself
but in relation to all other letters
will be huge and it is to exhaustive and
so it will require basically a computer
for you to do this and so if but but if
you do this the correct answer is one of
these sequences and so one of the
problems or one of the hindrances or one
other shortcomings of using the
algorithmic approaches that it it is
very tedious in nature it requires a
number of variations and so it is quite
impractical nobody has that much time to
go up and look at these many variations
no simple code breaking password
breaking how do you do it one of the
ways of doing a password hacking is
basically using or to basically do
ethical hacking is to use some people
the brute force now in the brute force
what happens is all combinations that
exist in to the dictionary is used by
the computer to arrive and the password
now if we do that and if it is assuming
that it is a seven-letter password then
we will have to do almost innumerable
number of representations right from a
in the first place to a 26 different
representations of the first place 26
different representations a seventh
place second place till the seventh
place and then in relation to each other
also using each representation so huge
numbers and so this is one problem or
this is one shortcoming of the
algorithmic approach what is the second
shortcoming there simply aren't any for
most of the problems in our daily life
so what would happen is is algorithms
are the best way to come up with a
solution and they always guarantee a
final solution what it turns out to be
is that for most problems on our daily
life we don't have an algorithm out
there and so we don't have an algorithm
out there then solutions are difficult
and then it becomes difficult for us to
come up with a solution because there is
no algorithm there is no true method of
doing it why because each new problem
daily life problem is a new one it is
not an exact replica of some problem
that we have seen and so that is one
thing another interesting way of coming
up with solutions to problem is using a
theorist now what is a yearís these are
general strategies or rules of thumb
that can be applied to various problems
so basically then one way is using the
algorithm another way of solving a
problem is using a shortcut and this
shortcut or mental shortcut or rule of
thumb is called a purist so this serves
as a shortcuts through problem space
what Urist are it and these are fixed
ways of solving a problem or these are
fixed ways of how do we go ahead and
bypass the all great algorithm some
steps of the algorithm so these are
water
Kuras so given the strength and
limitation of human problem solver along
with the fact that most problems are
ill-defined they are relatively large
problem spaces heuristic problem solving
is more effective the reason is since
the problem space is huge since any
problem requires a number of big problem
space and a number of subproblems into
it what people tend to do while solving
problem is using a theorist what does
the here is do it gives you some kind of
a shortcut so what is the shortcut it is
in terms of bypassing certain types of
the algorithm now since we know that if
we come to know that
two three four or five of an algorithm
always gives a particular answer for
example mixing yellow with green gives a
particular kind of color and if we know
that we need not repeat this each time
or mixing the Tilly's into boiling water
and boiling water always gives a certain
kind of color or a certain kind of taste
and flavor we need not repeat this again
and again and so we can jump by stating
that if you mix tea into it this is the
kind of color that we are going to get
and so this is basically what is called
the heuristic approach of
problem-solving for example how do we
solve the same problem so in terms of
algorithms we saw that we'll do n number
of manipulations we'll do these six the
different letters are there and we can
manipulate we can do all number of
arrangements out out of it and then come
up with a problem a good purist of how
to solve this problem is that thinking
of gkv k and i KN are not possible so
English words do not start with this
kind of beginning and so we can
eliminate these kind of or these
different starting with it and so these
are eliminated and we can sell since use
more huge and then come up with the
final answer that VI ki ng is the final
solution because this is the URIs it
says that if in your understanding or in
your in your life you haven't seen in
your readings you haven't seen any words
starting with gk v k VG or i KN and so
these can be eliminated this can be
ruled out also look at this particular
things now it's a daily shopping
experience and if you do that basically
or if you would think that you are
shopping what most people tend to do is
something called roundup and so one easy
way to solve this problem is rounding
this to 20 and rounding this to $30 and
rounding this to $30 so 30 30 60 70 80
is not answer
so $80 is what you are spending but
already the approach says is that we
have to add up 9.95 0.98 0.97 generally
speaking most people will say that I
spent up
eighty dollars so if you're purchasing
three the item it is $80 which is then
what I have done is I have rounded up
and this rounding up is called the
nearest or this is the problem or this
is the mental shortcut so the fastest
way is to basically go ahead and round
up and this is what is called the
heuristic way of solving a problem
a third way of solving a problem is by
using a means-ends analysis now what is
a means and analysis now basically the
general problem solver which was done by
Newman in Simon
it basically utilizes a URIs known known
as something called means-ends analysis
now what is the MA
it involves basically breaking a problem
so if this is my problem state initial
state and this is my goal state and what
then happens is that means ends analysis
says that I take this problem and draw a
break into four different parts and each
of it which is solvable and then what I
do is I then this becomes this part then
becomes my initial state one and this is
my goal state one so I first think of
solving this part of it and then when
this goal state now becomes my initial
state to problem two I solve this part
of it then I solve this part of it and
then I solve this part of for example
think about launching a rocket now if I
want to launch a rocket this is a huge
problem now I can then divide this
rocket launching into several steps for
example thinking about the physics of it
thinking about what material should be
used
what kind of fuel should be used so they
would do people who will calculating the
fuel calculating how the rocket moves up
calculating things like what what is the
material that should be used and so
several people are this launching or
rocket can be broken down into several
types rise from the physics to the
chemistry of it the physics of it and
several other systems in which should be
tearing through the electrical
appliances and so on and so forth
now I solve this one part one part by
one part and then I come with the final
solution or a simple thing that if you
have a car it is not starting now if the
car is not starting brake this
starting of the car into several sub
part for example check the key checked
some the ignition check the battery and
so on and so forth so several solutions
are there and I arrived from one one
solution say to the nurse solution says
the first step is to raising up the
bonnet to identifying where the battery
is to testing the battery to basically
then testing some other facts the
electrical circuit stressed in the fuse
and then finally arrive at solution of
this problem how to start a car if which
is not starting so then the MEA it
involves breaking up the problem into
smaller several sub goals in which
accomplishing each sub goal moves the
solver close to the final goal of the
problem solution as I said if you are
tailed the if you solve this huge
problem if you make the shield problem
into smaller problems and solve it one
by one or solve parts of it one by one
you will finally arrive at the solution
as the term implies in MEA the solver
systematically attempts to devise means
to get to the each sub goals end ma can
be effective way of transana the
effective way for solving a
transformational problem now look at
this problem and if I want to solve this
remember this is the solution to it
thank so from state one where it was
here to state to where it was here there
is a solution to it and you can see the
solution so on the right hand side I
have the solution so this is how the
solution really looks like from moving
from this state to this state this is
the number of solutions and so it
realizes or you have to realize that the
problem has to broken down into sub
parts there are certain constraints and
so if you break the problem into sub
parts you will be able to solve this
problem as it is now when you actually
another way of solving a problem is
using analogous problem right and so
what we do in analogous problem is that
we think of a problem when reaching at
the solution of a problem we think of a
problem which is similar to the problem
which is at hand and then we tend to
borrow certain features or we tend to
look at the similarities with the
problem which is at hand and then think
of the problem which which we are
thinking about which is represented in
our mind and then solve it for example
I'm giving you a problem now the problem
and I will give you a solution to it so
the problem is that there is a person
and he has to be treated with lasers now
the fact is that if this person is given
a high-voltage laser a treatment what
would happen is or a high-energy laser
treatment what would happen is the
single focus I mean single ray of laser
light is given to you with high energy
what will happen is the organ which is
diseased in in in this case that will
disintegrate or it will burn up and so
what is the solution or what is the
solution to this problem how should we
treat but then this organ can take in
small or can only take in small laser
energy values right so it cannot take in
a high-energy laser it can take in small
energy laser if you if you give in a
high energy laser from one direction
what will happen is the
instead of curing the problem instead of
curing the cell which is disease the
whole organ will burn up so what is the
solution the solution here is using
several lasers which are low powered
from several different directions now
what will happen is the since the whole
organ is not surrounded so it is
basically in this case what has happened
is if I give one laser with a high value
high value laser this organ will burn up
so what I do is I use several different
lasers which are smaller in energy from
several sites so then since it is each
laser has a very low value it is not
going to burn up the organ it is only
going to hit upon the particular cells
which are diseased and also the fact
that the total energy of all these
lasers will be the energy which is
required to one of their cells so I can
then distribute it across no analogous
problem is there is a military officer
who was going to go ahead and capture a
particular fort now the only problem is
the fort is bounded by certain bridges
now he require a certain amount of army
and certain amount of tanks to be taken
before fighting the war but the fact is
that each bridge is going to or each
breach has a certain limited capacity of
carrying the track now he has to take
ten tanks and but each bridge can only
take one tank and a few soldiers onto it
so how do how does he go about solving
this problem and all of us - what we
have though if he can relate the his
problem the major or the commander of
army can relate his problem to the
problem of this this particular laser
thing what he could do is that he can
use several bridges and each bridge will
now hold one tank and then each of it
will arrive at the enemy fort and can
actually win the war and so this is how
analogous problem or analogous problem
solving really works now in analogous
problem solving there are two things to
look at once in terms of comparison one
is the company called surface versus
structural features so what are the
primary steps in solving problems by
using analog involving the use of
mapping the original problem - the new
problem basically what happens here is
that in terms of what we saw that you
have to understand the commander of the
army has to understand that how his
problem
winning the enemy fort is similar to the
medical problem that I defined before so
he has to go ahead and map these two
problems together or basically make a
one-to-one relation between his problem
and the problem which Virtua which was
the medical problem now yeah can her
geek and holic
they termed this mapping process a
schema induction he says that this
mapping or this identification of
one-to-one identification of the
elements of the medical problem and the
elements of this war problem how they
are related together is basically called
schema induction now I ability to notice
map and develop schemata depends on
particular type of similarity so we look
at similarities and the more similarity
a particular section of the problem
particular part of the problem has to
the new problem which is out there the
more similar the more easier it is for
us to solve now these two can be of two
types so we look at two types of
similarities one is called the surface
feature similarities now in the surface
feature similarities what happens is
specific elements or the problems are
Mac if two problems sure they share
specific surface features we believe
that it is same and then we go ahead and
basically map the problem together
for example paper jams know if there is
a printer and all of you are very
familiar with what a printer is so if
you have a printer at home and it it
gives up paper jams then if I take you
to a new printer and if I introduce you
a new printer you will be more or less
similar you will understand that the
back of the printer is there the roller
is and so that is where the fact where
paper jam is and so it will take you
very less time because most printers
work in the similar way it uses the same
kind of roller mechanism and so you will
always look forward for where is the
back button or owning a printer and so
you know that the the central switch
will be big and it will give you the
affordance of pushing down and so no
matter what printer I am giving you with
the idea that the most printers require
this kind of this kind of build up you
understand that pushing this button is
what is going to
help and so this is called surface
similarity mapping in structural
features although the surface features
although two problems may not look like
each other but then there are certain
unique features are the certain
meaningful features within the problem
itself which would look identical and
that will make solution of the problem
easy and so in the case that we
described below
the commander has to realize that
although the other problem was a medical
problem but the same kind of solution do
exist for example in this case in
understanding the structural features
two problems are structurally similar
they may look quite different on the
surface and underlying similarities
would be there for example looking at
the two sentences one is active wise the
other is passive wise if we look into it
the dog chased by the dog chased the cat
or the cat was chased by the dog both of
them although structurally they are
different but meaning wise in terms of
the meaning in terms of the semantics of
it they mean the same thing and so both
the problems are structurally similar
now another interesting thing to look at
is in terms of how do expert solve
problems so experts have something which
are called expertise which are
exceptional knowledge performances is a
certain specific problem domain area so
now it's Ron's 1950s experts are now
viewed as the product expertise is
basically seen as a product of innate
capabilities but nowadays in today's
view expertise is seen as more of a
skill memorizes so according to Erickson
and Paul since 1988 skill the memory
theory there are several differences
between how an expert or how unknown
novi solves a problem first experts have
highly rich semantic networks it
basically means that the semantic
network the thinking network the network
through which they solve problems are
highly developed or highly connected
with each other experts have quicker and
more direct access to long term memory
so most experts can easily access long
term memory because they have done this
problem solving this kind of a problem
over and over again and so they have
quick access to long term memory then in
terms of what our nowise could do and
information is more easily encoded onto
long-term memory by experts and the
speed of the encoding improves it
this now if for an expert he can
understand quickly the problem the the
parts of the problem quickly represent
the problem in the correct format and
quickly find out the problem space also
find out the correct operators and can
solve it for novices the problem is the
problem arises the hindrance either
right from the very beginning where the
representation of the problem as reacts
as a hindrance and even if the
representation is there they might not
find the correct operators and so this
is the difference between an expert
enough nowise problem solving now what
are the advantages when expect problem
solver the core of the problem solving
is memory the long-term memory that
allows for storage know of domain
knowledge and general information of
specific episodes that working memory
there allows for quick and efficient
online processing of the information so
basically studies by Chase and Simon
1973 and DeGroot 1988 at a point that
experts can instantly recognize problem
configurations based on extensive
knowledge and experiences so what
experts tend to do is they quickly
repair understand a problem when they
look at a problem they are very easy in
understanding or they very quick in
identifying the problem configuration
which means that problem representations
is very easy an expert they will very
quickly identify a problem now Ericsson
and Creech in 1995 they proposed the
idea of long-term working memory to
explain expert advantage in in online
processing of problems now the theory
states that experts can bypass limits of
the working memory by using the
information or the working memory to
direct access to LT M so what experts
can do is they can bypass these working
memory storage capacity problem and they
can using the working memory directly
access the long-term memory and so this
is the way how experts are better also
expert problem solvers use general
strategies that differ from those are
the no wise release to searching the
problem space in a forward fashion then
reaching from the good
so what experts tend to do is they when
given a problem they don't think about
the goal state and and travel back from
the goal state to the problem state what
experts tend to do if they use novel
strategies they use effective strategies
and they always move in a forward
direction from the initial state to the
goal State and that is why they are
faster in solving a problem then
coming from that goes straight to the
problem state experts are much better
picking up on structural features of the
problem and recognizing analogous
problem so experts are not fooled by the
surface feature of a problem they always
look at the meaning they always look at
the at the conceptual level how a
problem is different from some other
problem and so they are easy they are
easy and understanding the structure
these structural problems and
identifying analog of solutions to it
and Lamar and Ziegler in 1995 proposed
that adaptive strategy model which
distinguishes between experts and
Noailles and what does he say
the strategy existence experts have more
number of strategies in disposal since
they have solved problems in so many
ways
or they're solve so many problems they
have something called the newer
strategies or more number of strategies
at the disposal then then no wise also
strategies based based rate experts in a
given domain of knowledge which
strategies tend to work and select those
strategies so in a given domain of
knowledge for example looking at math
expert they tend to know which formulas
are going to work will formulas are not
going to work and so there tend to be
very choice e in using those strategies
or using those formulas which are going
to work and not those formulas which are
not going to work so they don't do
foolish acts what they tend to do is
only those strategies are used by
experts which tend to work and they use
those strategies over and over and the
third thing is strategy choice refers to
express advantage in discerning which
strategy should be chosen for a specific
circumstances
so they're very quick in identifying
which strategy should be chosen over
which other strategies and how these
strategies choice works with in
circumstances work with environment so
what is the relation between environment
and statically and they're very quick in
identifying which strategy is going to
work and which strategy is not going to
work or which strategies to choose and
which strategy to not choose and for
this strategy execution they first do
that expert advantage in actually
carrying out the strategy in terms of
speed and accuracy so basically even if
they know our strategy no wise would not
be able to basically implement this
strategy with speed and accuracy but
experts what they tend to do is since
they have used strategy a number of
then no war strategy is going to work
and they have a number of strategies at
they use they also can execute the
strategy fast with higher speed and IR
accuracy and that is how they differ
from the otherwise but then this is not
the only thing there are certain
disadvantages also
for example nowise are better at
understanding randomly arranged problems
and experts know I can focus on two
problems or elements of the problem
which experts will not focus on since
experts are always directed at solving a
problem they always look at those
factors in a problem which require a
solution or which give them a hint
towards the solution and so they tend to
overlook other features or other answers
in a particular problem also nowise
remember more information about specific
problems and experts and this is termed
as immediate amid intermediate effect
now what happens here is that no wise
since they look at a problem study the
problem wholly they understand all parts
of the problem right what experts tend
to do is pick up only those
configurations which need solution or
which have solution and so one once you
ask both the expert as well as the
Noailles about basic questions relating
to what the problem was no wise will
tell you more about what the problem was
and not the solution faster but experts
will not be able to tell you what the
problem the overall problem was they'll
only look at features of the problem and
how to go ahead and solve it and experts
may actually we saw actually solve
problem using mental set as compared to
no wise users no experts make this
mental set of a solution of how a
particular solution should arise our
particular problems will be represented
in solution should we approach that and
they use mental said whereas no wise
don't have these mental set and so they
can have varied solutions they come up
with multiple solutions although if not
correct it may not be correct but they
can come up with these things and so
they are different from experts and so
in what we did in this today's lecture
is we looked at the different type of
problems solutions which exist what are
the problem hindrances to the problem
solutions which are there need a
comparison of various problem solving
techniques and at the end of it we also
looked at what is the difference between
or how experts and novices before with
each other
in terms of solving a problem thank you
[Music]
you